so hey guys we r XG 1 2 7 and this is my
yeah Wow alright let's go right to
questions then suffer beam yeah ok well
that's a lot of questions
oh let's make them one at a time ok yeah
oh there's one to find k-pop star I mean
kpop stands for Korean pop and uh that's
it basically just become a star today
specifically you have to be from Korea
we have Chinese members and Japanese
members and also Korean and American and
Canadian members so I think that doesn't
matter
ya know do they need to have the same
fan base that uses similar terminology
or do you just need the aesthetic you
gain a teeny bit of luck again a song
about get gum okay today a todai-ji boy
okay
consider that automatically one guy to
keep cutting wood or a staple chrome got
me beggin TiVo for any bacon evil I
think maybe my new career goal is to
produce a kpop music video how do I do
that with NCT yeah you gotta see I'm
waiting for you welcome just you gotta
have our name under your belt by mere
sage I don't understand all these giant
k-pop groups okay
when there's so many of you how TF do
you guys get along
J'son go get in young about another I
wonder would you give them water when
you having it yummy dominate take a
cocoon jang hee-jae panel burdock tea
cool don't worry team cutting you wanna
contain clover Anika widow
bo-gyung dormant idea
King Johnny Tomita Jamie got die dancing
on my tongue got you
it might get a little rowdy at times but
I think that's a good thing as well
and also it's easy to get along because
we have the same goal and I think that's
really good to have yeah
we're like a big family yeah Daisy
leaving Australia Austria Australia
Channel yo does anyone know how kpop
concerts work I'm planning on attending
to over the summer and I've never been
to one
like do they have acts that open for
them like American ones do kpop concerts
they vary depending on the artist and
depending on the concept but usually
it's mostly without open actors usually
the k-pop star in itself when I'm a
modern concert my wooden mudiad
MOCA a single cone and a chunk of
shiitake ah she's a cousin Julie yes it
equals to go in there it's in Buddhist
man Amado goo hyung cocoons up to it
Windham the throw Isaac wah wah
we want you to come waiting for you
Shelley Shelley okay I'll do all the
kpop stars have such nice skin
what why did you they drink Adi this
isn't easy
holidays it okay Gooden in bruising
Allen Dana are you looking your eyes are
not the Korean water maybe it's good for
us Lavar oh yeah visit your I know how
k-pop groups get their custom outfits
made like do they outsource them or do
companies having out have in-house
designers we have Li a style designer
and they actually come in and be like
measure our length and everything like
perfect measurements yes it's like
perfect
what are you little eggle dojin I yeah
Hut I humble birth how in the world do
k-pop stars train I mean they dancing
robot super MC we Koo Yong dong zero and
then we stop at each moment
degree we measure we measure a whole
thing
angles we gotta get him sharp you know
it's like knives practice we get a ruler
even if you guys aren't right really
yeah like the smallest amount you know
I've gotta go again you gotta take out
that protracting whoever gets it wrong
they have to buy sushi yeah
[Music]
from Meredith please how do kpop stands
learning Korean with our songs
yeah are they like a social media
content and I guess they pick it up from
that as well yeah yeah NCT life yes
things outside of performance as well
where everyone can learn Korean yeah
yeah yeah love makes you learn there's a
guy in there my mother
your Cheney blog about and we're still
learning Korean too let's be honest
Google see Korean drama Bailey from
Bailey um how did the kpop stars keep
their hair looking so good even after
dying it so many times
treatments tree a tree much yeah how's
your body Banja what do you got cookie
santolli oh haha as long as it looks
good you know yeah it looks good
at still BBH how do you all balance the
kids social life and kpop well teach me
how I'm dying here
professionals well thank you guys for
sending so many questions through
Twitter this was wired kpop support see
ya thank you thank you